[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys we're here at the Mortal Kombat
11 reveal the doors just opened fans are
filing in but I'm actually here to
interview some fans that you might
recognize to talk about their experience
from oral combat and kind of what they
expect to see at today's festivities so
come on in Swifter same here we got
great a beer thanks times like this
event looks amazing yeah it was like
real life is real now what did you do to
prepare your Mortal Kombat fan I am I'm
not good at the game I'm terrible I love
the story love the characters love the
fatalities grew up on it like it was
like it's a little like Delhi Nicholas
was a great school I think and when more
comment won first came out was like wow
like real life graphics in a video game
obviously not the case these days but
like it's just been a part of my life
growing up and so for you I'd like to be
at this event to be part of a big reveal
we know that some secret characters
might be revealed so who are you hoping
to see so character wise I mean I don't
know there be some surprises but I want
to see like features wise like moral
Kombat 10 that the awesome fact and
system injustice to had the great loot
system like they're always gonna be like
crazy ways that kind of push the fighter
scene so I can't wait to see what it is
helping you see like some changes or
some new things integrated we will
definitely see it's about hope it's like
what is it gonna be you know it's gonna
be awesome so they never let us down and
for you when you were a young kid and
you were playing this game what
attracted you to the game and what do
you think makes Mortal Kombat so lovable
that is what you know obviously like
very gory you know the fatality is like
no game was like pushing those batteries
look like real and this was like cool
it's like you know like any kids fantasy
of like being the game and like you know
bring something spine or throwing them
at spikes it's like you know I was like
great going up so stop I don't normally
get to do exactly number will get to do
what about for you when it comes to
playing against a character that it's
just really hard to beat and you kind of
hate playing again I mean I just
complain like you know I'll just get
saucy swiftrage wherever like I just get
angry by you got to do it it's all part
of the challenge is very satisfying the
story is always great just like you're
motivated to kind of like keep on going
and so you get better and you just and
you get it done so absolutely
and are you gonna be checking out some
of the boots here today absolutely don't
know what the tattoo booth but the
fatality but there's so many crazy
things going on here so it's just what a
wild event like I'm really impressed so
it's not expecting it to be like this
grant it's gonna be even more epic so
stay tuned of course for everything
that's going to be announced here thanks
a lot for joining us today all right
later
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right welcome back I'm here with
dynasty how's it going pretty good
I'm excited to be here this is crazy
honestly this is insane you guys are
watching this I wish you could be here
because they went all out do they not it
looks crazy that's a moral Kombat fan
what does this mean to you everything
I've been playing this game since that
was probably like Ford not a good thing
I don't know my parents was thinking buy
me an NES SNES and Mortal Kombat 1 I was
four and I grew up playing it and who
would have known that like 20 years
later I'd be here I like the MK 11 evil
event it's insane so I'm stoked did you
know you could get a tattoo here of like
if you want you could get Raiden you
can't you know what we should do we
should have the twitch chat decide
what's that - I got are you actually
gonna do it real tattoo I'll do it I
love that you're a true fan I'll do it
I'll do it
twitch chat decide for me I'll do it
perfect now of course as a fan I need to
know who do you main like who's your
favorite character zero without a doubt
get a Sub Zero tattoo I'm willing let's
do it let's make it happen why not let's
do it what do you love about Sub Zero
and all the characters in the roster
he's like the one character it's always
been like in every Mortal Kombat game
ever and growing up who doesn't want
somebody who can just simply freeze an
opponent run up through an uppercut so
we saw scorpion already I'm really
hoping you see some sub-zero today cuz
scorpion looks sick and hopefully
cenotes too so any returned characters
you're hoping to see back to the
franchise return characters rain Fujin
noob saibot
the list goes on and on a lot of fan
favorites of Sandow Serena million so
I'm just excited to see what we get
honestly even some new characters - and
you'll get to play of course the demo
here so looking forward to that like
it's everything is shaping up to be
amazing so far so awesome well I hope
you enjoy the experience there's a lot
of different like pop ups here you can
even like go into this big box and
thrash a bunch at break break up a bunch
of things and like okay taking the rage
and like become like a moral come back
here I figure there's six the tattoo
idea though
so I think we're doing the tattoo I'm
gonna follow your social platform and
take a look do it let's do it I'm gonna
do it see that all right dude thank you
so much cut later guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright guys I'm here with Bethany who
is a cosplayer and you're here I can't
believe your costume well if your
cosplay I should say you look wonderful
thank you
what what did it take to pull this
together how long did it take you to me
yeah so Mortal Kombat reached out to me
to work on this project a couple months
ago and I put this together in about a
month
so since the reveal at the game Awards I
basically got to see the costume and was
able to build it for this event so I'm
thrilled to be here what made you choose
this character retold we want you to
dress as this character did you get to
choose like one of your favorite yeah so
I've actually done a couple of gender
Bend scorpion cosplays in the past and
that kind of you know brought me a
little bit of notoriety in the cosplay
community so they reached out to me
because of my scorpion designs so they
wanted me to do that again so I was
pleased to be able to do that it's
intricate where's there any particular
piece I was really hard to make in
particular you have a mask so I had to
sculpt everything out of clay I posted a
time lapse video of like my whole build
and it took a long time to do I was
worried I wouldn't have enough time to
make the rest of the costume but I did
it though it looks stunning and what
does it mean to be here are you moral
crime assuming your moral Kombat pan so
like what for you is the thing that
you're most excited to see and
everything about this event I'm just I'm
just thrilled to be here in general like
I kind of started cheering up over there
just absorbing everything so I'm just
I'm just happy to be here I'm happy to
see what's happening I'm happy to see
character reveals like new costumes
maybe to make and just it's so
incredible just just be in this
environment
scorpion your favorite character of
course get over here
any return character some of who might
not be your favorite but that you really
want to see back to the franchise yeah
actually I was talking about this early
I'd love to see LeMay from deadly
alliance I really love that character I
played it all the time on the Gamecube
and Mortal Kombat is finally back on
Nintendo so I'm thrilled to see that and
I don't know I'd love to see kind of a
nod to that era
well you seem like a true fan you look
like a badass I'm very excited for you
to be here and for you to see of course
I've kind of got a little taste of
what's coming so I'm very excited for
you to see what I got to see and I think
you're gonna be blown away you're gonna
be really excited I can't wait well
thanks a lot for joining us here today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys we're back I'm here with
uncaged what's up dude you're excited to
be here I can tell I'm super excited I'm
I live a mortal kombat it looks amazing
and I'm ready to see what they have to
offer so I'm assuming you prepared or
did something to prepare for this event
so what did you do to do that I went
back and played Mortal Kombat 9 the old
MK games MK x I'm fresh I'm ready for
what the story for MK 11 gonna be did
you come up with new ideas of things
you'd like to see I mean a big thing
that people are saying is time travel so
I want to see more about that time
travel for sure all the story like kind
of it's a very crazy story and it's hard
to keep up but you seem to be really
invested in that what do you think
people love about it I mean a lot of
people love that
Mortal Kombat is one of the fighting
games that actually has a story other
fighting games like yeah it's a base
it's a good fighting game omoro calm
it's a good fighting game and it's a
great story as well so with a great
story comes great characters what are
some of your favorites and who do you
hope returns to the franchise my
favorite character of all time is Johnny
Cage that's actually why my name is on
Kate's game so I gotta have my boy back
your as a perfect person to be at this
event yes I if they reveal Johnny you
can see I'm gonna jump out of my chair
for sure you better get the camera on me
I'm ready any fighters that you actually
are not so keen on fighting against
usually when you play um noob saibot
he is my number people love him I do not
like him I'm sorry I don't like him and
I don't
he's coming back I'm pretty sure but I
don't wanna why don't you like first of
all eyes there's a noob second of all
because people that play them they're
noobs as well they just spam the same
move and I'm like to stop so that's why
I don't like it
alright I love your excitement level
your energy it's super great I'm so
excited for you to see what's gonna be
revealed back here things were about to
get started
we slowed down a bit but I
I'm just very excited right now I'm so
excited I can't I want to jump up and
down right now all right well thanks a
lot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello folks I'm here with chloe dykstra
one of my good friends what's up hi
darling how are you good
you're beaming today thank you that's
funny that you see that because I'm a
little sick I feel like I sound a little
bit like maracas right now well you look
great and you know thank you so much I'm
here at the event you're right we're
clearly excited you would go if we were
sick have you got wandered around this
event yet time to see what they don't
eat since seeing on the tower in the
middle the tower in the middle there's a
literal tattoo parlor over here you can
customize shoes 18 Staton they went all
out I mean my thing for me when I look
at the booth is like I see that rage
booth or the experience where you go in
and you get to like destroy things to me
that's like I need to get some it's like
good therapy I think I would be terrible
at it I probably go in and smash
something like oh god I'm so sorry how
do I put it back together I'm sorry I'm
so excited to see what people are gonna
take away from this event of course
there's a ton being revealed we can't
talk about it yet but it's it's coming
down now there's cosplayers hanging out
behind us and everyone's kind of gearing
up and getting ready so it's moments
away I'm very stuff can I ask do you
know anything about what's about to
happen
I know yeah I got to see everything
yesterday they told me nothing so we get
two minutes with you guys I get to
experience it with you guys
so I'm very excited I want you to see I
want to see your live tweet oh yeah I
couldn't do any of that yesterday I know
that's the thing that's the hardest is
keeping it under wraps you like saving
drafts even drafts okay yeah so thanks I
think I think we're we're about ready to
get started very soon and you're gonna
be hosting as well I will be I will be
interviewing a couple of these amazing
artisans a lot of people from the Mortal
Kombat
unity you're here we have cosplayers we
have sculpture sculpture it's okay
that's a term filled your slots of
artists it's really cool there's a lot
of awesome people Gary so thank you yes
and feel better all right
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys I am Chloe filling in for Naomi
right now I am here with some amazing
cosplayers would you guys like to
introduce yourselves yes I am Xavier
woods aka Austin Creed aka host of the
greatest youtube channel of all time up
up down down go subscribe if you have
yet to subscribe already I am see you
tonight
okay Zelena Vega from Debbie w/e i am
Kofi Kingston no AKA s just me
Michael Mosley Michael it's lovely to
meet you so I want to ask really quick
first of all you are the creator of some
of these costumes you crew did you
create this for yourself yes I did yes I
love coming to these events and seeing
all the amazing costumes will you okay
how many of you are actual wrestlers
raise your hand all three of you guys
are wrestlers so you guys are all used
to being in costume at this point yes
right now we were wearing more clothes
than we normally do on TV so all right
so why did you choose the characters
that you don't yeah I mean obviously but
like for you personally why did you
choose these characters I love seochon
he's the man now but how can you love
him though
he's emperor's in charge he's a badass
but as he but can you love can you
really love it was my heart and soul
how about year with white white jade I
feel like Jade is very underrated and
some people kind of take her for granted
so I got a rep for those up I nice night
I mean sang sung you just represents he
can be anybody like that's your dream as
a kid right who would you be when you
grow up
Shang Tsung can literally be anybody who
wants that's anybody you know I know
Shang Tsung has a name for school but
have you oh my gosh there's actual fog
coming out if you miss you oh my god
that's amazing okay well we have to
actually move on which bums me out
because they also see an amazing katana
and back can I just really quick really
quick show us you offered in your Vince
awesome thank you guys so much for
chatting with me you look awesome you
did an awesome job
and
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
mercy is wasted on those who defile
birth ground
[Music]
[Applause]
moans plain savagery is no match for
skilled
yet again the gang
chosen destiny
[Applause]
I will destroy our enemies before they
destroy us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please welcome the producer of the MKX
pro league and combat class your host
mr. Joshua gray is Los Angeles and hello
to everyone watching around the world
welcome to Mortal Kombat 11 the reveal
I'm Joshua green I'll be your host for
today's monumental event are you all
it's excited as I am to be here today I
hope so because we have some truly
awesome stuff to share with you and I am
so pumped to reveal some of the
surprises Mortal Kombat 11 has in store
and I've got some excellent guests here
to help me out
Edie Boone and the NetherRealm Studios
team are here to talk about the new
storyline and the tons and tons of
content they've been working on for you
Tyler Lansdowne is in the building along
with some of your favorite Mortal Kombat
pros plus we have some secret special
guests in attendance that I can't wait
to bring up here including some
real-life badasses behind our characters
in just a few minutes you will be the
first people on the planet to fully
experience the bone-crushing brutality
of Mortal Kombat 11 prepare to get hyped
we are about to reveal even more
gameplay for the first time in a
worldwide premiere this is the most
blood splashing gore spewing spine
snapping action you have ever seen in a
Mortal Kombat game ladies and gentlemen
please welcome to the stage
creative director of NetherRealm Studios
and the co-creator of Mortal Kombat
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Edie
you and your team at nether own Studios
have done it again there is so much to
unpack here and I'm sure you can't wait
to dive into some of the gameplay you
know you
we've been biting our tongues since you
know six months ago around III dying to
dying to show you guys this game but we
really wanted to kind of build the
suspense this is absolutely gonna pay
off for that all right and I'll let you
do the honors take it away
yeah you guys first I think the first
thing you wanted to do is see the actual
game so just let's let's just roll them
here
[Applause]
so we're very excited to show you first
look at Mortal Kombat 11 nobody else has
seen this today we have seven characters
to show you some returning some new
there's far more in this game we'll be
able to show you right here but we do
want to hit on the enhancements from the
game of fighting and the custom
character variations
[Applause]
Garrus is a new fighter in the game and
who can she has a really cool time
control abilities you know mortal and
NetherRealm games we really try to add
something new Mortal Kombat X we
introduced a feature call the character
variations three versions of every
single character MK 11 is expanding on
that idea
creating custom character variations the
player can actually create the eye
themselves so you notice that selecting
different versions of scorpions some
operated by the player some are created
already in the game
same thing with maracas
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
suck cotton warriors are legendary
why don't you free are thrown back the
[ __ ] I taught you embrace nature short
so this is a Mortal Kombat games to
expect the fighting to be brutal MK 11
sees the return of Baraka is a fan
favorite from Mortal Kombat 2 so let's
see some of the moves he does here
that's to be outdone scorpion has a few
tricks up his sleeve okay now without
getting too technical getting into some
of the key key fighting game Bob what
moments are their mortal comp
traditionally we've had one meter that's
a shared resource amongst the offense
defense and the super moves
Mortal Kombat X isn't separating all
three of those so we have a horizontal
meter as the offense attacks vertical
meters the defensive attacks sepal
rockets gonna shooting to using his
offensive moves also can extend this leg
staff here into a throw with a also
scorpion here is going to escape up from
a knockdown using his defensive meter
and you're going to notice here that the
fatal blow is that's actually tied to
30% of the of the health meter when is
reduced you get fatal blow available
this adds completely new dynamic and
tension to the fighting both America and
scorpion have a fail below right now
Baraka wins this fight
so scorpion missus fatal blow attack but
it actually will regenerate after a
cool-down period so you notices his
fatal flaw is established they can pull
it off
[Music]
and now to be outdone Baraka now has his
fatal blow available
and of course it wouldn't be mortal
combat without fatalities
[Applause]
[Applause]
to date
[Applause]
we're gonna quickly talk here about we
have custom variations on this player
various screens that players can create
modify and collect multiple versions of
every character there are a ton of
features that you can customize from the
costume pieces the intros the victories
as well as a huge variety of skins here
every console every fighter has three
costume pieces you see scorpion they're
changing the mask here picking a new one
you can actually program these at
different attributes see we're swapping
out the spirit or the katana for a new
one
and of course scorpions iconic spear can
be swapped out for him as well
now this visual here is going to give
you an idea of a kind of like the
dramatic differences you can have in the
different variations of scorpion hair
this is the case with all the fighters
so you're going to know a scorpion Barak
all the kind of variations you're going
to see you know playing people online
and whatnot
our second fight here is Sonia versus
versus Scarlett who was a returning
character from Mortal Kombat 9 trust
both Sonia and Scarlett return with
their classic moves as well as some new
ones Sonia has a bunch of gadgets that
she can play with here while Scarlett
has her signature blood attacks
we're gonna take a look at some of the
nuances we have we have a new feature
called a flawless block a perfectly
timed block will open a window for
countering attacks watch Scarlett doing
a quick hop you can evade lo attacks and
also open another window for countering
room now I noticed
Sonia's health is reached below 30
percent when it reaches there again
you're going to notice the fatal blow is
available that's when you can throw a
devastating
again Sonia has her fatal blow ready so
she can take release it
[Applause]
so that was enough damage to release
fatal blow available for Scarlet Witch
she'll attack here
which is enough to win the match and you
might seen a glimpse of this fatality
here
[Music]
so that's a little piece of MORTAL
KOMBAT 11 but i guessing maybe you guys
want to see some fatalities a little
more more okay we're gonna roll this
footage I can't wait for you to check
that out through this
[Music]
[Applause]
okay first of all Scarlett has returned
what has it been like to bring back this
fan favorite that we haven't seen since
Mortal Kombat 9 yes we we introduced
Scarlett as a DLC character in Mortal
Kombat 9 and she's been one of the most
demanded returning characters so we knew
we had to kind of abide by that I know
everybody's scarred out there super
stoked as well all right we saw some
classic combatants like scorpion
sub-zero plus we have dark Raiden and
Baraka
is back we saw Baraka rip somebody's
face off so okay we also have some new
fighters for you and your team what is
this process like not only to create new
characters but to refresh some of the
classics refreshing and deciding which
ones that comeback is pretty much you
guys you know we really hear we hear
what you guys say as far as creating
characters that's that's some of the
most fun we've had you know Garris is a
new character that we have a really cool
look at you're gonna see a little bit
later but that process is usually very
collaborative with you know the people
looking forward to that folks so we
witness combos fatalities but one of the
hallmarks that Mortal Kombat has always
been the rich detailed stories so what
can we look forward to in Mortal Kombat
11 when it comes to the story yeah you
saw a glimpse of the beginning of the
story here we actually have a video here
it's the entire opening cinematic the
whole prologue of the story it really
picks up right after MK 9 and I think
you guys are gonna get a big kick out of
it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
silence you know
[Music]
but you wear my amulets finally you
embrace the truth the elder gods deny
the truth I was just out for speaking
the truth
I embrace shinnok is that mercy is
wasted on those who defile earth realm I
will destroy our enemies before they
destroy us starting with you
[Music]
not even you can kill an elder god
there are fates worse than death
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I will deliver you to okay and your
NetherRealm engines you'll serve as
warning and an emblem of my
[Music]
[Music]
this is not your destination aku once
again the Thunder God has upset the
balance of history no this
the arc of universe bends to my will
[Music]
it is only a matter of time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
edie that was amazing April 23rd cannot
come soon enough
so the story picks off right after MKX
dark rain rains time is being
manipulated how fun was it to dive into
the rich mortal kombat lore and design
moments when these legendary characters
confront of different version of
themselves
yeah that was the most fun about you
know how we created the story we
basically introduce a character chronica
who has been kind of running the show
since the first mortal kombat everything
that was happening was it to her plan up
to the point where Raiden kind of screw
things up and that's when she's kind of
stepping in and she's just gonna play
tricks with time that's gonna introduce
situations where old characters meeting
their younger selves and it's it's it's
such a great great story mode we could
not be more proud of this Ed Boon thank
you so much for being here give it up
for the legend ladies and gentlemen now
I have one more question before we go
what other changes have you made for
this installment we have something
really special for Mortal Kombat 11 we
have a real-life badass playing one of
our most iconic clear-text
characters in the game and we cannot
wait for two to make this announcement
let's take a look
you've been looking for me starlet
right so new blade calling an air
support
Sonne blade was the first like kick-ass
girl that I saw come onto the scene and
I've always admired her and admittedly
kind of emulated her and you know in my
own way and now I get to try and be here
the first time I can remember playing
Mortal Kombat my mom was a college
professor and one of her students
actually let me play and I was
completely like button masher but I was
braided in and I beat him as Raiden it
was like the first time did I beat an
adult and like anything yeah I thought
it was like the absolute coolest
boy see a character has been really
different and really interesting and fun
because I don't have to think about how
I look and only about how I sound it
almost gives me permission to be as
ridiculous as humanly possible because
no one's looking at no one's judging and
all that matters is what it sounds like
[Music]
I've been in a mortal combat for almost
as long as I can remember for a little
kid I love me some more
[Music]
what drew me to Mortal Kombat honestly
it was the first game that had like real
intrigue of just more than okay I'm
gonna hit this guy hit me and who wins
it wasn't just like who was the better
fighter it was why is this person mad at
that person and this and that it just
drew me in to think about more than just
fighting but the world that they live in
and yeah it's been a great experience
being Sonya buddy
[Applause]
please give a warm welcome to the
reigning raw woman's champion the first
woman ever to be inducted into the UFC
Hall of Fame and the voice of Sonya
Blade Ronda thank you so much for being
here how does it feel to be part of an
iconic franchise like Mortal Kombat and
to be voicing Sonya Blade this is a
dream come true I really I tried to grow
up to be Sonya Blade as close as I could
like I feel like if Raiden came down
right now and had to pick three warriors
Mortal Kombat like I would definitely be
that person and now instead of being the
closest thing I can be to Sonya Blade I
am actually Sonya Blade
earth realm is in good hands so how did
you prepare for this role is there
anything that you did specifically to
get into Sonja's headspace or things
that you pulled from your fighting
experience well it was very secretive
this project I really didn't get to know
very much at all and so I I tried to
inhabit her headspace by by actually
emulating her fighting style and I got
to do her Khurrana on Triple H at
WrestleMania so he was Makino for the
evening and I've been watching the the
gameplay and Sonya actually does a
rolling duty Khatami armbar that is like
my absolute favorite she does rip
somebody's arm off with it I can totally
do that
and so yeah I was just getting my inner
Sonja what excites you most about Mortal
Kombat 11 they really do outdo
themselves every single time and when
you don't think that they can do it
anymore I mean it's it's blowing my mind
I mean I didn't think the grab is to get
any better and they obviously are I mean
I have no idea what's going to happen
like with the rest of story I know my
parts but even still I'm just like
there's so much secret involve that I I
just cannot wait to see how the story
unfolds I there's just there's so much
that I'm be probably ignoring my family
for a while and showed up in a room
don't worry we're all taking off work
now I already know the answer to this
question but which character are you
most excited about for Mortal Kombat 11
Sonya Blade of course
even though I kind of hope I see Johnny
Rhonda thank you so much for being here
ladies and gentlemen give it up one more
time for the voice of Sonia play the
Mortal Kombat 11 Ronda Rousey more
dreams coming true next up I want to
invite someone you all know and love up
here to talk about some of the things we
have coming up for you on Kombat cast
this year please give a warm welcome to
Tyler Lansdowne great to have you man so
tell us what's going on with Comcast is
here so excited to be here for real
reveal of MK 11 there's so much cool
stuff coming up this year and I will let
you know right now that our first combat
cast is in less than two weeks January
the 30th that's right around the corner
what do you have plans well the first
one's gonna be pretty big new logo we
got a few surprises in store for you I'm
not gonna talk about it right now but
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa bro
was that who I think it was yeah we're
gonna wait until the 30th to find out
you're gonna want to re-watch that and
see that is our first comeback has to be
live on every single Mortal Kombat
social channel I don't want any of you
to miss this okay we got so much good
stuff coming up but I need to ask for a
friend okay is there going to be a
collector's edition actually yes there
is a collector's edition this year and
it's badass and I want everyone to see
right now what we've put together okay
that mask looks incredible what is it
you have won just walk back there this
is one the coolest collector's edition
we've ever done in addition to this mask
if you preorder any version of the game
you get Shao Kahn and access to the beta
which begins on March 28th man I I don't
want this I need this put me down for
one I am sold and you can purchase yours
two at your local gamestop here in the
United States for everyone else around
the world get more information at Mortal
Kombat com that just about wraps it up
for us here on stage but stay tuned
because we have a lot more coming up
with a live stream of Tyler you're gonna
be interviewing some folks and a live
look at the reveal floor here in Los
Angeles and a pro exhibition featuring
some of your favorite Mortal Kombat
combatants we do have one more big
reveal but first a big THANK YOU to Ed
Boon and the NetherRealm Studios TV for
joining us and of course Sonya Blade
herself Ronda Rousey for being here
today
she's great and I want to extend a huge
thanks to everyone tuning in from all
over the world thank you so much for
being a part of the Mortal Kombat 11
reveal we hope you're excited for the
official release of Mortal Kombat xi on
April 23rd Oh so Josh mentioned the
reveal just a second ago are you ready
to see it here we go
[Music]
[Music]
thunder lightning do you feel nothing
Garrus nothing within your power rate
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
fatality
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys it's Chloe again I am sure
you're sick of me already but I am here
with Kyle Hill of the famous because
science show on YouTube we are so happy
to have you here at you are you excited
to be I'm very excited to be here I've
been playing Mortal Kombat's since I
think Mortal Kombat - if I had to guess
really button mashing since Mortal
Kombat 2 with my brother
it's very fond memory of him beating me
that's pretty much OD what was your
character back then and what's your
character now I'm a scorpion fan I do
like I do like ogee scorpion I love to
get over here spear and all in all the
original moves and move sets and so to
see how the game has progressed and
evolved especially as you know I don't
just do science II things I'm also I
play a lot of video games so to see how
far it's come from something like
probably the game I played most was
Mortal Kombat 4 on the n64 I believe and
to see where the graphics have come from
then until now with this where it's just
so good and so pretty where every
fatality every crushing blow kind of
makes you queasy and a good way I'm just
gonna ask you about that because as a
scientist which you are a scientist what
biologically
how realistic are these fatalities well
I can say that coming to an event like
this gives me a lot of potential ideas
for stuff to do but obviously in a game
like this things are kind of cranked up
to 11 in terms of what is physically
possible or not what I will say is that
the force required to rip a limb off or
punch someone's face off from behind
their head is a lot a lot of these
conservatively Wow I don't think
conservatively speaking a lot I mean the
kinds of forces it would take just to
lift a human off the ground with
something like a punch is somewhere
around the same amount of force that a
car going highway speeds would hit you
with so it is it's substantial well I
think it was heavily hinted at in the
trailer that there's a time travel
element in this game potentially is that
something that you might be excited well
time travel is always super confusing in
that the universe seems to not want us
to go backwards only forwards if you go
really really fast you can go less
through time than other people do which
is kind of form a time travel but in
terms of going backwards I think I'd
like it more for the story element than
I do for the physics element because I
don't think I mean it if Stephen Hawking
couldn't figure it out I don't know if
we're going to so you're saying to me
that mortal kombat is not realistic as
what you're saying I'm saying did you
hear that mr. bones whoa I'm saying that
shots fired
mr. moon I'm saying that mortal kombat
is heavily drawn from mystical things
and it's fun to watch that's true it is
very fun to watch where can we watch you
you can watch me and all my science II
pop-culture evideos at youtube.com slash
because science and maybe some Mortal
Kombat stuff will be inspired me here
awesome well thank you so much Kyle have
an awesome time
I'll see you guys in a few
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys it's Chloe yet again I am here
with code Abdo aka boss logic you
probably have seen his art it's
everywhere he's an amazing artist it's
so nice to have you here you're not
you're obviously a big MORTAL KOMBAT
obviously yeah what was that like for
you that whole I was crazy then was your
favorite part the new Tom charcoal
character it was yeah it looks pretty
awesome
so it's give you some inspiration for
what you're gonna it feels like a my
favorite is buck the strange so it feels
like Doctor Strange I can totally see
that so I actually I stalked her
Instagram a little bit recently and I
noticed that you posted something like
this big Instagram post talking about
your journey is an artist and I thought
that was really cool because I feel like
a lot of people out there are sort of
struggling with themselves and their
talent do you have anything that you
would like to say you guys if you boss
at box logic on Instagram you should go
read this post it's really wonderful do
you have anything that you would like to
say it is just not to be scared anymore
I say there's bigger things like this
but this is my first time coming to LA
or leaving the country in the last 20
years this is your first interview first
interview as well as you said you're
doing great but yeah just I wasn't gonna
come here until I posted that post so
until I got the feedback and like the
support I wasn't going to come but now
thanks to the people I came to oh we're
really glad to have you here I mean it's
it's awesome I mean there you have so
many fans what does that feel like
have you been some of your fans here I
meant like maybe ten of them but it's
crazy people who's saying oh that's my
logic that's Muslim
it's logic well it is so awesome thank
you so much for being here and letting
me chat with you any final words anybody
I'll see you in April see you in April
awesome thank you so much high-five have
an awesome time I'll see you guys in a
bit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys I'm back it's Chloe again and I
am here with a fitness queen and cosplay
extraordinary this is Alicia Marie you
look fantastic by the way I have seen
you and maybe five or six Mortal Kombat
cosplay I'm I'm ridiculous with Mk it's
like a classic for me it's like if I can
old school of and I've just been with
the game for so long in my life that if
I can just do every character I think
I'll be very happy I think you're
getting close I think I'm seeing you as
Jade Tania
so note several types of stone throwing
the blade was like okay I am so excited
about Ronda Rousey being sonya blade I
cannot deal with it because she's
turning such a badass they needed to
have someone he was equally a badass to
player and she's perfect so I'm really
excited to see what Sonja's gonna bring
it okay leather I agree now I gotta ask
you because this is kind of a gender BEC
cosplay this is sort of the first gender
event Mortal Kombat cosplay I've seen
you do what was it like to translate
this particular skin into like a
feminine outfit it's not even it's not
quite feminine it's like a fighting
outfit okay shut condors a [ __ ] you
know he's a a warlord he's pretty much a
demon like he's crazy I mean I think is
an amazing he's an emperor he's like
everything that a badass should be I
particularly like the collectors edition
skin because the kind of harkens back to
the samurai look that the designer
intended for the character anyway and a
lot of my cosplays like to pull on what
be Paris design originally wanted for
the character so I like that when I was
making this I got to research a little
bit of like samurai style and the colors
they use and the design for the helmet
but it's really lightweight though but
it's not heavier that's awesome I gotta
say also by the way like you were such a
badass yourself I feel like you versus
Shao Kahn you might actually have a
fighting chance
really quick before amendments cuz I'm
so I'm guessing but you know how long
did it take you to make them okay let's
see I started making this and on
December 10 when I saw the I saw the
sneak peak so I was like this Oh cuz I'm
gonna make I was gonna make someone else
and then I was like okay I'm switching
gears everybody tonight side so I made
it under guard making a December 10
December 10 yeah I mean are you serious
so this took you a month to make took it
I finished it about three days ago so my
god you're throwing things around you
were absolutely brilliant okay that's
like trying to fighting these things I
can't be better resin it's just actually
resin right here Roger
oh this is 3d printed thank God thank
you God for thaty printing the symbol
this is a purple so cool I am so
impressed by the way you guys can
actually get this skin if you preorder
the game right now Mortal Kombat 11 I
mean not exactly the skin but something
very similar to this skin so go preorder
it Thank You Alicia so much you are
wonderful thank you I know me too
figure out we got some more interviews
coming up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everybody welcome back I'm taking over
the interviews for a little bit I have
some good friends here sorry if I have
trouble hearing you it's nuts in here I
got I got maximilien to this crew so I
was gonna pass the mic down tell her
about who you are if they don't know
which they should know who you are pass
it down and we'll talk hi my name is max
I'm here with Kenny and Simmons we're a
three out of four of the old video games
screw big Mortal Kombat fans we made
three live-action mortal kombat fan
films since MKX and are very much
looking forward to this awkwardly
beautiful game this game looks too good
Tyler I have a problem it looks too good
I think the art team with everybody back
at home and neither one would really
love to hear that big shout to them real
quick for making such a beautiful game
that we get it lucky enough to talk
about I'm gonna send the microphone down
the line I want you each to say
something you're most excited about I'm
gonna say the thing I'm the most excited
about is the new mechanics between all
the different Mortal Kombat's they
always have crazy different mechanics
between mobility between offense and
defense now I haven't had a chance to
play the game so that's the thing I'm
the most anticipating maybe I can get a
walkthrough from Tyler if he's not too
busy we'll see we'll see what's up I'm
Kenny from your videogames the Mortal
Kombat fanatic of the group this is my
Oscars this is why I have the tux
whistle oh I can't look sharp because
this is my Oscars this is my thing and
I'm most excited about the customization
like making the character yours like
sometimes you get a fighting game and
you're like oh you know I love this
character I just don't like their look
this one you can really customize your
look and get it the way you want I can't
wait I can't wait to start customizing
every character in this game and make it
in my own hi there i'm matt from yo
videogames and kenny kind of stole my
thunder a little bit on that because
really am excited about the
customization and then the way how you
can really make a character unique to
yourself but i also really like the
commitment to the story mode and seeing
how that's going to continue forward
because they were very upfront and
committed to saying we are going to
continue right from the last game and
it's going to have that high production
value we've come to love and expect
that was a beautiful outline of what we
just did
mechanics character's story awesome
we're very excited to have you guys here
another question uh what was it like
being in the crowd seeing some of this
stuff for the first time was there one
moment that really kind of put it over
the edge for you i I think the big
moment for me personally was just the
final reveal of how the game actually
looks like we get the representation and
the perspective of the CG trailer but
once you see it in motion and it's like
oh it kind of looks just like the CG
trailer what's going on and it's also
the fact that there's like an
encompassing energy like I've never felt
this way like I felt the world was
involved and it revealed from Mortal
Kombat in some way and everyone is here
to celebrate a fighting game and for me
that that's something special
it was amazing being in the crowd I was
next to a lot of the tournament fighters
I was next to my friends and the energy
was out of control man and just seeing
like the cinematics of the game like it
was almost no different from the
cinematic trailer once tuts happens and
it's just it's I still have to take a
breath
I think the moment for me when it really
like sunk in how big this was going to
be was when Baraka showed up and Baraka
was a huge crowd favorite and he was the
talk of the town in Mortal Kombat 2 when
it first came out so it was kind of like
his nostalgic wave of people getting
excited and for me it was like when I
saw the first gameplay reveal the colors
popped so well it's so colorful
yes it's violent but it is colorful
violence and it's wonderful well I think
that's all the time we have for you want
to tell them real quick where to find
you
we're over at twitch.tv slash
Maximillian underscore dude and you too
bad maximilian dood as well i'm unruly
you and roo li e that's on everything
bro youtube twitch and you can find me
on my youtube youtube.com / EO video
games and the twitch stream at a system
e doom all one word thanks a lot guys
we'll be back a little bit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys it's Chloe I am here with
Christine McConnell of the curious
creations of Christine McConnell I am a
huge fan of yours I have been a fan of
yours for a long time not to just be
like but seriously you you are such an
amazing creator so if you're not
familiar with Christine which you should
be she is a master baker and she scores
she does amazing photo I should let you
just describe all of the things that you
do I wouldn't know where to start you do
so much it's so funny because I don't
know if I've heard like would you
describe yourself as kind of a nerd very
much yes you would just have you would
you what kind of nerd are you
specifically um I would say like kittens
and sewing I don't know like it's funny
because I actually I was like all right
oh my god I get to hang out with
Christine McConnell tomorrow you've done
some amazing stuff for the Mortal Kombat
community I've seen cookies you made
some cookies can you describe your
cookies yeah what should we call it
I sort of researched a lot they had
reached out to me to see if I could come
up with anything and after like
researching as much as I possibly could
I thought I'd put like a comical sort of
spin on it so I think the first project
was I think at sub-zero yeah I saw that
the most adorable sub-zero of everything
I know some gingerbread cookies that
looked a little alarmed and I just tried
to do something fun with it so yeah how
long did it take you to make because I
think I've seen two cakes and cookies as
well so how long does it typically take
you to make a project like that honestly
forever I want to maybe this last cake I
just did I think it took six fold 15
hour days oh my gosh it's a long time so
what I was saying is that I I ended up
googling because I was curious to see if
you had ever done cosplay because you do
these really cute photo shoots in them
I saw that you kind of have done cosplay
before yeah I have a big Wonder Woman
fan and like I'm trying to think
Ghostbusters you'll I watched that movie
like once a month so I gotta say I
almost think that baking in a way it's
like its own kind of cosplay I think so
definitely and I don't know the sky's
the limit you can never run out of
things to come up with that is true
thank you so much for being here with us
it's an honor to have you here at this
event I hope you will have a wonderful
time stick around guys there will be
more
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I am excited to have some of my favorite
people right here I've run into you a
thousand times we just met very exciting
we need to have words so let's introduce
who we got here
I am Xavier woods aka Austin Creed aka
host of the greatest YouTube channel of
all time up up down down go subscribe if
you have yet to subscriber already and
I'm sale con right now I'm sorry
superstar Selena Vega and I'm dressed as
Jade I am Kofi Kingston right now I am
saying soon damn right you are
alright so I want to ask a question when
I go each each one of you what do you
anticipate for this game what's what are
you looking forward to what do you want
what I've been anticipating is seeing
Baraka and I saw Baraka and I lost my
mind and he's nasty he's biting flesh
off he's eating people's brains I'm so
looking forward to using Baraka in this
game more than anything else and I feel
like everybody has their own unique
style so it's really cool to see how
they're all gonna get destroyed I was
gonna say fatalities too but honestly
I'm looking forward to the storyline I'm
so intrigued there's so many just I have
so many questions like the new
characters and just like their
interactions you see raining out there
torturing people what is happening in
the Mortal Kombat universe right now we
need to get Kofi back in the studio to
get bodied by 16-bit again remember when
that happened hey that's that I'm sorry
I brought that up you are a guest in our
home and I apologize everybody wants to
get on me why why all I'm trying to do
is live my life look I bodied Selena and
in Mortal Kombat on several occasions
and look okay we're gonna have one more
question what moment of the show made
you made your eyes pop like what did it
for you mmm back to Baraka I know I said
it already but him eating the brain come
on come on son what so dope
I love Baraka
I have to agree with that but I also
think when Raiden and sliced his head
off should knock when he sliced his head
off that whole interaction really got me
so for me it's got to be Scarlett's
fatality and number one like she did it
the first time and the second time she
did it it was a different color eyeball
so the eyes change like the details are
like come on man like you got the
different eye colors come on her
fighting style Oh negative come on man
we had some fun with those scorpion hat
boons Maine as one if you saw that yeah
so guys we're gonna wrap it up I'm so
glad to have you guys here I am sure
I'll see you again real soon because now
we're all like best friends cool thank
you for tuning in it's been it's a
wonderful day glad to have these guys
here can't wait to hang out for the rest
today we'll catch you later
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome to body count fighting
ladies and gentlemen I'm your host
Joshua gray and we are live from la
fresh off the Mortal Kombat 11 reveal
now what better way to celebrate Mortal
Kombat 11 that with the series of pro
exhibition matches so body count
fighting another own Studios have joined
forces to invite a handful of
NetherRealm pros to compete in Mortal
Kombat xi for the very first time
backstage we have Hayat a honeybee curve
scar Tweety dragon rewind and of course
sonic Fox mortal kombat xi is getting
ready to showcase their skills featuring
these players they will take the stage
to compete a series of first two threes
to establish bragging rights and set the
tone for the upcoming pro series our
commentators are standing by as the
first match is about to begin
gentlemen let's get this exhibition
started hey alright my name is Ultra
Dave and I'm one of the commentators I'm
Steve Braun back from another room
that's right so from the home of NRS
that's right I'm today's home my
hometown in Los Angeles super super
excited here we have eight of the best
and justice - and Mortal Kombat X
players in the world competing in the
first look at competitive Mortal Kombat
a level so I was just talking very
briefly with Skaar about it he they have
all had a chance to play at the right
point but keep in mind not for very long
oh this is beyond this is way earlier
than meta 1 this is yeah yeah who can
find sort of one thing in the last
little bit of time that they've had to
play yeah they've literally had about 45
minutes so it's almost like you pick
your favorite character you just kind of
go it I kind of think I know
so we're gonna have Hayat a versus
honeybee you were the best Canadian
players in the world both top eight
finalists in injustice and MKX actually
mm-hmm and two of the just the best film
world in general also Tweedy versus
Dragon which I'm extremely excited that
those are I mean Tweedy is one of those
hype players and in Dragon he took a
break from injustice to just as Tweety
kind of ascended to a top player so this
is a very fresh match yeah I'm
interested in the hats gonna go
stylistically too then you also have
scar versus grrrrrr
which is I mean they had an amazing
match again just as two pro Finals it
came down to the wire and they are both
again contrasting play styles for sure
yeah yeah heartbreaker for their sonic
box and rewind as well it's also a
rematch
that's a rematch of them playing every
night online as well as every tournament
that's ever happened it's true yeah so
we're gonna get a look at you know
hopefully a smattering of different
characters it's just up to the players
which ones they want to pick so we'll
find out yeah I was in the back area
watching them play and they were all
playing different kind of characters uh
everyone was talking about playing as
Raiden but who really knows when you get
out there and sonic just probably used
all seven already yeah yeah I imagine so
alright well let's go back up to the
stage and see what's going on
thank you gentlemen
all right folks without further ado
let's introduce our first player from
Montreal representative pan de globo hi
[Applause]
so battle for Canada my friends so good
to see you how pumped are you for Mortal
Kombat 11 I'm really pumped to come in
and try the game experience what it's
like to play it and I'm living in a
great time and all right man excited to
see your game played go ahead and take a
seat let's introduce your opponent
hailing from Toronto East Coast honeybee
welcome my friend what do you plan to
bring to this game being such a huge
Mortal Kombat fan well in the last game
I was known for playing Devorah a lot
since she's not here right now I'm gonna
use Baraka and chop chop chop to victory
chop chop chop it is go ahead and grab
your seat we give you a sec to get ready
on the button checks as they choose
their character these two professional
players have been competing in the
Mortal Kombat scene for a quite some
time we're to give them a second just to
check out and log in and get ready for
our first matchup in the character
selection screen right now there is
Baraka who we saw earlier today featured
in that beautiful presentation from Edie
Boone and you can see the menu right now
all of the different options these pro
players go through to make sure they
lock in what they need to be their best
and it looks like they're both ready and
waiting for high on say for his last
button check here hi I'm say ready honey
be ready gentlemen let's get this match
it started to the commentators here we
go i'm super hyped scorpion is the exact
character I predicted Hayat they would
play okay it's perfect sense because
what he didn't go high all day crazy
showman
mobility yeah excellent footsies as well
and I've already seen some good tools
from scorpion in that yeah one of the
big things about this game is most of
the characters use weapons and they
definitely use them well like scorpion
now uses his sword more than he ever has
and he has excellent range she's kind of
been reimagined as a mid range combat so
let's talk a little bit about how the
game differs from MKX what are some
things to look for right off the bat one
of the big things to look out for is the
new meter system there's now us two
stamina bars there's defensive and
offensive an office is what you use to
do amplify your moves defense is what
you use to do wake up attacks or wake up
rolls or our new breakaway mechanic and
we have our first crushing blow that's
another one in the new mechanic okay
there are certain moves five or six per
character where they have different
properties for example doing the move
three times in a row or countering a
high attack or punishing a move and you
will get that x-ray effect that need to
time oh man i popping damage mind
blowing damage and they also can have
properties like they can pop you up or
rescanned you they're significantly
better versions of those moves when you
get the crushing blow effect so that
meter just to be clear it just comes
back on a timer it's not really today
there's no longer meter building by
doing moves are taking ship damage there
it's on a timer you can almost think of
it like a cool-down okay and it is a
very fast cooldown if you've only used
one bar so you definitely should feel
welcome to use your amplifier it was a
lot but if you have none right now you
can see could not do is amplify teleport
right
oh you can see Baraka chunky not bad one
very smart
I started gonna read that teleport I
think right there but you can see
there's that back one I think it's old
it yes back what is this or move yeah
incredible button right there yeah it's
a lot of the characters play their best
at that kind of in range
oh here we go let's see I gotta tell you
guys I don't know if you could hear that
in the way that I could but I have big
ol headphones on my ears right now and
each one of those little blood droplets
I feel like was in my head our audio
department does an amazing job of making
something gross like ten times gross
with asti yeah so talk to me a little
bit about movement in this game seems
like run is not there what is completely
gone instead we really wanted to make
walking one of the key things a very
old-school 2d fighter thing you can't
actually - but the dashes don't really
go that far and they have a lot of
recovery so they're mostly used to like
maybe when you have sub-zero freeze to
get there quickly or if you want to take
the rest because they have a lot of
recovery walking is really the name of
the game in my opinion you can't cancel
a dash with a block or an attack if you
want reminiscent of them k9 but yeah not
nearly as effective as it was back then
where you would kind of - block
graphically to get it you really have to
think ticket in ice which then goes with
what I'm saying about the normals
it's so much rain so the normals have a
lot of range at mid-range and everyone's
using car weapons but the walking is
really strong see we kind of walked in
and out of that range easy okay yeah it
seems like already from about this range
they can play footsies yeah overhead is
huge right and one of the things we want
to do is we definitely wanted to bring
back they're really exciting offensive
MKS but we've looked at the overheads
and the lows and they have a lot more
risk reward factor to it like Baraka
does happen it's a 70 cent it's like
almost an absolute overhead yeah but
he's not gonna get a copy right right or
scorpion does have a load of Chicago but
his overhead just slaps you down okay so
it's gonna be a lot rare to see like
they're really really deadly mix up stir
so we just saw a little short hop out of
scorpion what's going on there the short
hop is a new mechanic where you tap up
any low attacker they can either do a
punch or a kick and they're universal
overheads that will splat so for example
if you predict that Barack is gonna try
to throw you could do a short hop to
actually go over the throw and then do a
splat by the way we're playing first two
three is just so everybody knows so
potentially one game left here for honey
bee and honey bees just been dominated
by scorpion he really hasn't gotten much
going on in the back one range this is
gonna be one of the tough things we also
saw a couple of times in there hopefully
we'll see it again the wake up system
very different the wake up system is
drastically different so now you don't
do special moves on the ground like
you've used now you either it up three
- and you could access to brand-new
Universal wake up moves that are like
just for Wickham attacks
so the up three will be an advancing
move that kind of goes across the screen
they'll not knock you down they'll just
do a little bit of damage but they are
invincible you can't be it out of very
very strong are they safe they are it's
gonna depend on the character okay
they'll be see there's some variation
then there's the up - which is an entire
move and that actually pops you up but
they're not invincible - built with jump
attacks so you kind of decide and you
see okay he didn't get a combo but when
he has got more than 45 minutes he'll be
sure to curse Harry yeah again this is
all brand new to that oh yeah and there
you saw scorpions up three where he just
kind of slit his throat it didn't get a
pop so one way to protect its fully
defensible and is really strong and you
don't get much reward want to attack us
higher risk but you get great more and
there was the wakeup Raw which is you
tap forward or back and the flip stance
button and you get a fully invincible
roll that goes forward or back the only
way to beat them sensible is the throw
it's really really strong it is probable
yes it's terrible so you're not gonna do
any damage it's not an attack but you
get out of Dodge and it's very very good
and that's gonna take 50% of your
defensive statement okay got it
it's like I'm pretty rough for honey bee
right here I'll tell you that yeah he
really hasn't been able to get anything
going in coyotes also playing so fast so
now we seem kind of slowing it down
she posted her pic damage he goes from
dough overhead block that time
oh good blocking you can see the
overhead it does splat you and has a
really good range but it's kind of slow
right if you're really looking for it
you could react for it to it oh there he
did get the punish nice and now he's
gonna get a pop-up so it did he get that
because that was a punish exactly
there's a lot of crushing goes where the
clients do a punish and one of the neat
things is you can only do the crushing
blow once per game so you see that that
once you to Parata crushing blow you got
to pop up but that's the only time
you'll ever be able to do that okay
so one of the big things that the meta
in the game is deciding when you want to
do your crushing blow and actually
taking advantage of honeybee looks
utterly overwhelmed
ya know that's the face of how it land
so to be clear each car each crushing
blow can only be done once again right
yes correct while the character may have
five he could do five and all one match
but he can only do one particular one
one Tom got it okay alright well again
we're still figuring things out let's go
back up to the stage so you catch the
next match thick gentleman alright folks
let's get ready for our next matchup
please welcome from Brooklyn New York
from dynamic focus
[Music]
[Applause]
always great to see you bring so much
passion to your competitions how excited
are you to be here girl very excited I'm
happy to see everybody see all these new
characters new game the super stoked to
be here very happy moment I'm gonna make
the most of it all right going out of
seat and get ready let's introduce your
competitor from Texas currently a free
agent scar one question scar Sonya or
scarlet scarlet take a seat folks we're
gonna see this fan favorite from Mortal
Kombat 9 make a return with one of the
best players on the planet we'll give
these players a second to double check
their button checks see what they need
to do in order to maximize the potential
in this game and remember they've only
had a couple hours playing this game but
it shows how long they have spent
playing previous death around titles to
pick up the intricate differences we see
in the game play compared to Mortal
Kombat X we'll give them a couple more
minutes here as they flip through the
menu and set themselves up for success
who are you ready ger is ready scar you
ready let's do it
gentlemen match number two about to
begin this one's exciting for me well
I'm looking forward to scarlet I mean
she's back but she's very different she
might as well be a brand new care so you
immediately gravitated toward this
character you should probably tell
everyone why cuz he's very unique
there's no doubt about it yeah so
obviously he's the grappler bye boy some
other characters have that too it's not
just him but Branca also does have to
come and grow that's how the command guy
so so Garris has a really strong command
graph that goes really far at corner
carries excellent he has some good
buttons and mansome because there's the
command grab and you see how long he
holds you it has unique property where
if he's near a wall he that makes the
Sam wall and throws you into it it does
a lot more damage where that happens as
well he has a little kind of Atrocitus
sort of semi zoning as you saw right
there he also has some crazy stuff in
the variations and I'm not sure which
ones he ended up with here but he's got
some real nutty tools let me he has a
real one time move he has a mover he can
actually remove time from the clock he
is a very it's very he's like a hybrid
character of a weird kind of trapped
character and then let the command grab
yes yeah very very funky design but
these puppies right not a skylit the
range is incredible the scarlet is the
footsies queen the mid-range queen in my
opinion she has she uses blood to
conjure weapons and they all have
excellent range so when you're down
below a certain percentage of light you
get access to the fatal blow yes and it
is a huge amount of damage as you can
see round living damage it is big damage
is they have armor and armors not as
prevalent that has been in previous
games you're really gonna have to use
your bit range to just avoid stuff so
the fatal blow is gonna be one of the
best ways to have armor it is not tied
your stamina bar at all right which
means you don't have to use your
resources in previous games you'd have
to give up all your resources to do an
x-ray attack now with fatal blow you're
free to use it if you have 30% which
just inherently makes them so much more
powerful sure yeah you'll get it every
game every round the catch is once it
hits you can't use it again so one of
the men of the game is gonna be decide
do you want to make a comeback in round
one like we just saw her will never have
is fatal blow again now these use only
the whole game oh I thought it was round
wow that is really big they are absolute
game shakers that are extremely strong
but you only get the one caching that
was his command grab same one it's just
and at the wall that bit was saying it's
a little bit different and he can hold
the the button to throw them even
further
like carry them even further oh now the
fatal goes there for scar and that's the
crushing blow that so the way that one
works is the last hits an overhead of
the string if you duck block you get the
crushing blow he also has a low where he
does sand trap
so it's a 50/50 if they think you're
gonna do the the low sand move they duck
and if they find that overhead they lose
40% of the life because of the crushing
blow he's telling me his mix up his mix
up has a crushing blowing but light
through the boy I mean you can use that
once per game right so that's one of the
fun things about crushing blows do you
do you want to go for that mix up now or
later
I see okay
and we'll see a Gert basically made a
crushing blow and a fatal blow come back
right here out of nowhere they debate
your massive damage yeah you can really
see that I guess is the opponent you
really got to pay attention combos in
general in this game are significantly
shorter than they've been in the past
and they do less damage and they kind of
that damage you would get by doing the
cinematic proves don't you see the
Kabbalists guy already has what was it
two hours of gameplay so far so one of
the big things would be to use your
crushing or her fatal blow to get damage
instead of doing problems that's that's
not to see Campos are not still a big
part of the game yeah but they're gonna
be used someone less prevalent like
there's less moves that can't go without
using an amplified mover there's less
strings to pop you up it's gonna be more
about doing the big damage and big big
chunks okay here we go
can you get in that time now yeah
Scarlett she has like four different
projectiles so yeah Thomas reason to do
anything else is just holding onto the
space right here
but kind of pay attention to that fatal
okay Hale bow was available didn't end
up coming up scarlet is a good example
of how the offensive works in this game
her back to is that site move that's an
overhead but it does not pop you up and
it is unsafe and blocked okay but then
her back before that one that can cop
you up in the corner so she has a load
that could pop you up but she does not
have an overhead huh
oh he's really found a good tool oh good
job
how they let the cricket man grab didn't
come and scar right back to the zoning
you can see but the frustration is still
here one of the things I really love
about MK 11 so far is that these
characters that you've shown on this
character select screen are very
different so you have the credible
zoning coming out of scarlet front
Garris you have really cool command grab
mix-ups he's got some other funky stuff
as well if we were talking about really
good variations it alone it's there yes
and then he will also have characters
like sub-zero who has great off some of
the best offense in this version which
is unique sub-zero typically big up it
was a very slow defensive character I
really don't think he is in this one
he's quite dead right now
and Sonja's also has really really good
mix ups
you know Goro he's had a lot of heart as
a player looking pretty confident up
there and I'm really glad that Kerr went
with the big body you know he an
injustice to as the game progressed he
moved away from bein a man graph
character see traditional use so I'm
happy to see him back yeah I was very
happy when I went to but back there that
he immediately had picked gears it
really it seems good for mmm-hmm and I'm
very very hyped to see Skaar play
scarlet one of the fun things about the
development his game since we didn't
reveal it you know earlier was sitting
there waiting I can't wait to see some
of these you know which Pro players
gonna play which this character ni news
scar was gonna lose his mind cuz it mk9
he came in late and he was the best
scarlet in the world at one point but
injustice came out he never really got
the chance to like get her you know atop
a turn MLG topic even though he was very
talented even back time so at the
beginning of this round we saw that it
said first hit what does that do for you
now without meter and they say was no
more like first hit bonus ok because
meter recharges on its own it you always
unlike typically you do not you actually
start with all four of your bars Oh ding
the combo out of the way go alright
alright let's talk about ok that could
have been cool he'll get they're gonna
beggar it does have his fatal blow let's
see those good now at this point though
the round is gonna be very hard to win
so it might be why should that save it
unless he gets a few hits on and then it
would kill me
oh wow just goes for the sleep seal it
yeah I really like the mind game of that
having to think even as the person using
the tool if you should use it now you
should saving for the next round or well
it's definitely one of my favorite
things that we've added to the game oh
wow what's the condition on that the
condition on that I believe is two
counterfeits with that move in a row
okay I was gonna ask what counter hits
do but I guess do they they help with
that counter hits are typically used in
crushing blows otherwise they just it
just lets you know that you hit a
counter hit but a lot of are tied to
that okay and that's the thing when you
see punish come up that it was a
guaranteed punish and a lot of those are
crushing blows like for example that
right there if that it hit is a counter
it would have got the crushing blow got
it look how long he holds it it's
holding him like they're a small child
yeah they are compared to that big boy
and right back to it range where he can
control things got good buttons maybe
not in this magic but typically it seems
like that's true okay okay here it has
cylinders of the fatal blow he was about
to lose at nine that's definitely gonna
kill now again that means Kurt did steal
that round but you will not have it in
the fun on it scar still has his so that
means in the end of game scenario like
right there scar will have a huge
advantage heading into the spawn around
hoping to see some forward movement in
there that is the I'm not sure with the
call it's not puddle that thing you have
to aim that right that is not tracking
it
traffic he has close to medium and very
far and you can see when he amplifies it
as when he gets an hourglass and it's
letting you know the other one's gonna
come out so you can see what he's kind
of doing you put it out there and then
do all the moves walk in and walk back
and then it's gonna go and Skaar knows
you can't get he well we were talking
about weather guard Gert could make
another comeback it doesn't seem like he
needs it right now it's all on scar now
scar does have access to the fatal blow
all now it is on cooldown you did not
lose it since it was blocked but I'll
sing them to get cooldown still
available wool it just came back
unfortunately it's too late so then you
do have access to it more than once if
it's blocked or with okay once it
actually connects it's used okay Wow and
we've only seen it come up a couple of
times but talk to me about how throws
and throat sex work are they the same as
in previous Mortal Kombat those are very
reminiscent of MKX
k9 you use the opposite button to break
them they have a forward and a back one
a lot of crushing blows are actually
tied to throw and the requirement will
be if they opponent text the wrong way
you get the crushing blow and they do
Babli damage like scarlet has one so her
throat can do like 30% of you tech wrong
Oh sick okay it's pretty awesome
so as the defender almost riskier to try
to tech in some situations well that's
exactly it and you could actually if you
think they're gonna crow do an uppercut
because that would trigger the counter
hitting high attack for the uppercut
crushing blow Wow all right so it kind
of works both ways actually if how risky
throws can be interesting
he had gone for the international you
can still amplify interactable to get
armor it's one of the few ways that has
armor in the game okay
however normally and interactable takes
50% of your defense if you implement our
mer it takes 50% of offense and defense
Farmar across the board is significantly
lessened than it was in previous games a
lot of characters only have armor on
their fatal blow or a handful of days so
they're both fighting pretty good swings
right now and making the opponent block
a lot is there anything that they could
be doing about that yes one of the new
mechanics is flawless block it's if you
block an attack the last second within
just a couple of frames ship damage is
significantly reduced and you actually
break out earlier and it allows you to
punish things and recover faster than
you normally would
okay it's a very hard mechanic it's it's
meant to be kind of you really have
mastered the timing and you really know
your opponent well but it can save your
life like if you're about to die by ship
demons you can save you you also if you
reversal and Ovid flawless block you
have access to your weight of attacks so
the up to or the up three to use your
wakeup attacks you can do as a rehearsal
so I'll give you an example Oh after
blocking right like if you do subdue a
slide and I block it if I fall off
I can then reversal up to and get the
pop-up attack so like a great example
would be scorpions and hands teleport is
safe on block however if I have the
timing if I've mastered if I have sonic
Fox like reflexes
I can flawless block the teleport and I
can actually get a punishment no cannot
okay and this is like basically a dead
even match
they are both playing their characters
pretty impressive for how little time
they've had yeah I feel like they are
developing even as we're watching them
right now we've seen some cooler
pressure out of both yeah they're both
mixing up there's only willing you
pointed out earlier like they're they
understand their block strings up close
go away get out so that was the up three
one where she she doesn't really get
significant damage or a knockdown it's
more of a get off me tool and is that
safe
it depends on the character okay yeah oh
there he was for his a temporal at
management which is interesting because
while it combos he freezes time he
cannot to in one into him
it also takes one of his stamina that's
right there are certain moves or cancels
that will take stamina that's not like
you need to enhance it it just does that
it just does that which that's okay it
to an odd that wasn't anti-air cheese
and the way that move works is the
opponent is frozen and doesn't do a
reaction so obviously typically not perk
up and knock you away that won't and
they are both within fatal blow so this
is the scramble I'm so excited for in
tournaments oh we suspect try it but it
was blocked and now he's that match
point dirt patient right there I like
the anti-air we tested scars getting a
big combo now there is a wall run
interactable here that ger could use and
ger has never done a wall sooner wall
around that he hasn't use their yeah
ger is definitely probably the
interactable master in the scene yeah
known to be one of those there you go
okay armor the tongue not connecting and
that tongue is a really really good move
it has really good recovery it's that's
my favorite of rezoning tools II looking
good for scar we got available in Africa
though oh he tried he tried the armor
does not activate for a few frames okay
so while it's very good armor and it's a
good tool to have it's not full per that
might be about it yeah it's gonna be
good scar takes it
well that's really good back-and-forth
and I love seeing the display of
footsies from both I like seeing the
different offense two different timings
very cool I'm really excited to find out
more about you know how you triggered
crushing blows I think that's a super
cool mechanic that is something along
with the blocking option that you were
talking about that really requires
knowing the game in depth yes crushing
blows are definitely a lot of fun to
learn the requirements and I've now seen
them probably eight million times I'm
still high like every time so like
something my pretty saying I saw
something back there yeah like that
Baraka aren't one we're just bites your
arm and a chunk of flesh comes out man I
was tough getting hype watching the
reveal trailer and it's like I've seen
it a hundred times this week then I kind
of got chills watching in front of the
crowd it's like I knew is about to
happen
all right well something else you
mentioned you'd really like to see is
about to come up it'll be Tweety versus
dragon let's finish the stage this one I
can't be more excited for because you
know the loser is going to their hotel
and determine out the lights and staring
at the ceiling like these are too
emotional they're gonna deny they're
gonna night they're gonna oh this is an
exhibition I don't really care I'm just
here to learn the game I'm just
preparing for tournaments nonsense
these guys get emo when they lose it is
gonna be emo city in here I like that
dragon said that his MK 11 main is
unknown because obviously but Tweety
went all-in claiming it was Jay yeah he
only could pick four what we have now of
course I do know dragon least when I was
over there early was very excited about
scarlet okay very very excited yeah and
I have similar aesthetic characters we
likes doesn't surprise me at all well I
think it makes sense play style wise I
think with both of these player it's a
great fit there
they're both they both are so strong
when it comes to patient play they can
really outpatient opponents part of why
I want to watch how this matchup goes
because they both have that ability
they're doing it with characters that
they don't have very much
time-life right your your right that
their plate styles are extremely similar
it's why I think they're so strong and
injustice when it's interesting that
they didn't really play at their peak
because dragon took a break yeah as
Tweety ascendant yeah
that's true well let's go up to the
stage and we'll watch it very shortly
thank you gentlemen before we introduce
our next matchup I have an a-10 head
phone to give away of my friends at
Astro but I need the help of my
moustache brother mr. Aquaman if you
could hand this out to one of the hypest
crowd members out there thank you very
much sir one of the pillars of the
Mortal Kombat community
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
three two one cold all right folks
we've still got two more matches for you
introducing our first player from
Indiana simplicity - oh you gotta watch
that footsie game man we love your game
play we love your personality outside of
the game how hyped to you for Mortal
Kombat 11 I'm about to mob what's up you
also got your lucky controller go ahead
and take a seat we'll get ready for your
opponent to come on out ladies and
gentleman from Delaware currently a free
agent
please welcome Dragan he's already gonna
take a seat you wants me to come to him
for the interview hey buddy yeah I need
you hey so it's been a little while
since we've seen you at tournaments you
know being a champion and all that are
you prepared to be a champion of MORTAL
KOMBAT 11 yeah yeah I mean after all I
was ready to sit down and ready to play
I'm ready to win I'm just ready all
right let's get to it we'll give you
guys a couple seconds to get that button
check prepare to let's see which type of
characters who to be bringing to the
game today a huge thank you to all true
David and sixteen-bit for some fantastic
commentary as these players are playing
any exhibition matches for the first
time today they've only had a couple
hours with Mortal Kombat 11 we're to
give them a little bit of time to get
set up here I'm gonna throw it over to
the commentators as they break down more
of what we can expect in this matchup
gentlemen so I'm trying to ask you all
the questions that I can think of try to
get as much info out there as possible
but if anybody would like to know
anything in particular send a tweet to
either of us and we're happy to address
as much as we can
yeah I'm super excited for that so
Tweedy is gonna be like everyone's
favorite player in terms of hi
right in terms of personality
personality hi okay yeah here's what I
like about Tweety this guy complained
non-stop that he didn't get me the
adjusts to baby and he told us that was
the only reason he wasn't topped the
first year okay and now it doesn't get
any earlier than this he's right never
Lee on stage it's a third set of
competitive MK 11 yeah so my point here
is he's up against an evolution champion
and an MK X topic finalist Tweety I
don't know if you can hear you has
headphones on you have to win this you
owe us you told us you would be top if
you could play early this is it you are
not giving him an out huh no there is no
out he has to win this but you know what
I love about Tweety he's thinking
absolutely yeah uh you you can't blow up
24 his confidence because he just owns
him for sure yeah and he's made that
he's made it clear that he can back that
up yeah oh yeah I mean there's Knicks an
injustice to the end of those games
there's no question he was one of the
best in the world
yeah and this is his first opportunity
to be top early in the game's life which
is so important there's you know you
always want to be good early on and not
have that oh you know I came in late I'm
a as he would say necro so he is hungry
okay now on the other hand we have
dragon unquestionably that one of the
best injustice to players the dude one
Eva for sure but he took a break and
like it or not I think dragon is a great
guy and Vince Lee talented player if you
step away you step away you have to hold
that and that she's better so this is a
high-pressure situation for both these
guys they have a lot to prove right now
both these players have like the zone in
the past and you might think it's
strange to see Baraka for somebody like
sweetie but actually that fireball is
legit it's a big and it recovers very
fast Baraka you know a lot of people
have this idea he's the savage videos I
know it's
like he doesn't know what's going on
yeah no he understands zone and he's
better he's been in 2d fighting games
for 25 years now
I just come prepared oh yeah and because
that that enhance move is just tied to
the stamina bar you can use that pretty
regularly you don't meet her in a
traditional sense for that right and you
can just see there he does two of them
and he's already built half a bar for
another one it's very very strong
yeah now the nice thing about scarlet
stucco she actually gets the knockdown
so you can get the life through she
definitely has the zoning okay trading
it up but you know what's knees got more
life Brian
oh good jumpin yeah read it now there's
finally up close and OH
excellent throw tech you can see the
rock this board for there is big big
range
chop-chop-chop-chop has never been
punished ever in 30 years everyone just
talks about how they punishes and they
don't okay
you can enhance that tidy against its
whites for both bars
now dragon just used to Spain to blow
even though he might lose this round so
that could be an interesting gamble now
is Tweety gonna want to use his to close
the Souder just try to beat dragon if he
can well doesn't it
oh cool that is the grossest thing
closely the skin is wiggling up alright
I like how the brain is pulsating yeah
it's still there
Stefan still moving it's alright dragon
doesn't think when he plays I think he
heard me I'm just kind of front like
yeah he doesn't need that sorry I didn't
I just jump so yeah those fireballs out
of Tweety that really made a huge
difference in the way that that first
game went yeah I mean Tweety had the
life leave pretty much the whole time
and dragon oh that's awfully early look
at that damage I really like how much
Tweety's been using throws two throws
always great enough in games and now
smart Tweety immediately just goes for
the zoning and dragons gonna have a hard
time because the lightweight dragon
smartly just going in now
overhead on the end of that yep fatal
blows already ready and Tweety yeah
spending twice anteye if he was ready
for it down Sue's that sweetie I think
this is sweetie basically saying you
need to go back on your break man you
need to get out of here yeah it's dragon
gonna put up with dollars he's gonna
wake up here caught in the corner oh he
kept it going you stepped on it it never
ended all right there we go dragons
gonna get something going oh no and now
it's meat he's gonna go back to zoning
Baraka yeah
I expected the jump perfect this is
somebody who's been playing the fireball
and anti our game for a while his star
fire was just amazing yeah that was her
wheelhouse a little bit of harassment
big jump boots and again this is all
Tweety dragons in big trouble yeah you
can see dragons having a really hard
time dealing with that plate stark being
a big yeah and this is in the early you
got a hint at the Tweety figuring out
something real cheap real fast
and now dragons gonna have to adjust to
that if it's just one more game look
that's how it is when you have been
playing the game for two hours right
trying to decide who's the best it's not
long-term strats it's what did I find
that's wild today today and dragon is
very good at adapting very good dragons
not nervous right now he's thinking what
the hell am I gonna do looking for
solutions all right yeah for sure
the only problem for dragon is time
now he's gonna have the live flu oh the
time not right going in a little bit
more
now we're gonna see Tweedy's gonna have
a hard time zoning now cuz these look so
low on live well maybe not for long yeah
okay perfect jump top combo elbows ready
though you see tracking instantly just
blocking a lot doesn't want to take a
risk on that very very smart
now change sauce and play chainsaw
interactable you can use it from
fullscreen and you throw it or up close
and it goes into a crushing blow
yeah I really like this changing dragon
there's a lot more pressure from them
we're headed over there the tongue the
tongue is not talking submit however it
is very very good on block it's a great
sounding truly awesome hitbox on the
sparks as I went forward I really like
Tweety going to the throat this rock is
gonna kick her fullscreen and now when
you sleep you can go back to his real
house here this is what he wants to be
walking up maybe looking for a jump
nothing game Oh
oh hey one question I have can you combo
out of that crouching non string buttons
bucket down one special canceled into a
tongue yes that will profit okay okay oh
my god he kept it going still and
Tweety's on set pointer he's been a snap
it's kind of rude of him to litter this
Fight Club here it getting his face but
you know I often think the jacket wants
that space just that in this match if it
hasn't been working out right yeah I
think dragon definitely so yeah he just
um zoning with scarlet has been caught
off-guard by how good Baracus on exactly
yeah but okay is the blood ball does
that give you a combo opportunity it is
not it's just a lot of hit advantage
okay the variation he chose to use
though you can actually make the blood
loss slow or fast by amplifier so he
could put on a slow boat ball and cut it
along behind it or mix up the speed man
something about the hand the start of
that big part oh my god the hand parts
the workers it's absolutely it just
makes it so real that you're like
weights yeah
[Applause]
Oh dragon has fatal blow yes he wants to
go for it
Oh he tried to punish it got caught off
is it gonna do enough it's not but very
close any entire wave Oh and dragon is
still alive
oh let him see it yeah let him see it
there it is that could not have been
closer for Dragon to know we were just
talking about adaptation all he's got to
do is to more games like this yeah that
was definitely more offense so like we
said these are two of the best in the
world and they're gonna add they're
gonna adapt on the fly right they're
gonna change now we'll have to see does
Tweety have anything but on that
mid-range and throws this will be our
first competitive getting them out of
two maybe
and their folks just going out is that a
cursive or is it just animated assume
then that is a crushing blow
okay that is if she does the moon as a
punish or a counter she'll get it okay
I see yeah not an overhead but super
useful and very very controlled there's
also a full of very far version a low of
close feed even far so it's great okay
it's also great didn't block screens
she's pushed back so far okay that's
actually overhead oh it is absolutely
love the flat part my favorite thing
about the flag if you can listen is
there's a war drum or a war boy he puts
it down yeah I like to imagine he has at
our cotton white war bands got like a
hype man right into the foreground
that's like Mad Max fury road that dude
that's just playing guitar like that's a
job Baraka has one of those guys one of
his variation moosie could choose he
actually has different placards like you
can planted or actually hit it with you
and he you could see that Annette's feet
play break down earlier yeah I was
trying that out that gives extra damage
on the button so if he's near the flash
you can really radically change your
character with the variation system
there are all kind of wacky booms like
well you mentioned it earlier but Baraka
also has a command grab there yes Baraka
has a midstream command grabber he'll
actually jumps and leaps a if he could
choose to equip that if he wants scarlet
has several different deep up and
buffoon she has she could make it rain
flood from the sky she's standing in it
she gets a damage boost there's all kind
of variation moves you can choose from
there you go come on man okay he's gonna
take it was pretty close to set towards
me it wasn't like we were talking about
we did start to see some adaptations but
it just wasn't enough yeah she's
definitely she's gone we have a mild pop
off of Tweety yeah like you were
mentioning before you know he and Dragan
have had different paths track and
hasn't been playing quite as much in the
last half year year Tweety the opposite
I mean he's been grinding and he did
fantastically and injustice as a result
but the wonderful thing about the
tournament scene is it is there is
always the next day and Dragan is a pro
he is back that means he is he is all
and I expect him to do really well this
year no doubt I think for both of them
yeah we have a replay let's go back and
check it out
[Music]
yeah you're right her face was wriggling
I saw it yeah it's very very gross every
time I see it it's kind of gross yeah
everybody's really my reaction first
time I saw ya
kind of tough still going like this but
very very cool again to see that this
character of Baraka plays maybe in a way
that many didn't expect I didn't expect
that I thought like you were saying I
thought he'd be more pressure heavy in
Augusta maybe he has that variation but
this was not what we saw here yeah you
can you could make a subzero very very
defensive if you want or you can make
him like a mix up character you can you
know again we talked about gear as
having very radically different he could
be like a zoning tract character or
focused in the grapple he can actually
replace his grapple move with a combo
starter so he can actually normally
deras isn't really a combo character you
can actually just get rid of the grapple
and then he as study has the sand move
that he gets big combos instead so you
can kind of mix and match depending on
how you want to play woo
coming up next we'll be rewind vs sonic
Fox look at those ages those numbers
down I mean can what happens if you add
those numbers are we about at 16-bit
ultra David level unfortunately yes
every time like CDs like rewind is
literally still in high school that is
true it is true alright well let's go up
to Josh he's gonna have some words with
the players thank you gentlemen all
right it is time for our final pro
exhibition match let's welcome our first
player from a Las Vegas no ball rewind
[Music]
rewind we've seen your career explode
these last few years with NetherRealm
games are you prepared to continue going
up and up and up in mortal kombat xi I
expect myself to rise to the top number
one number one
take a seat let's get ready to bring out
your opponent ladies and gentleman from
New York the current reigning champion
of nether realm titles
Haeckel box on e5
[Music]
sonic you're the fan-favorite the
people's champion and the reigning
champion are you prepared to defend your
title in Mortal Kombat 11 hell yeah
laughs oh hell yeah take a seat let's
get started great to see you
and as always folks these two players
will sit down go through the button
checks and confirm they are good to go
to maximize their potential with these
characters back in MKX days at the fatal
eight sonic fox wowed everybody with
aaron black we've seen rewind use a
number of different characters
throughout his career but this could be
anybody's game in our final bro
exhibition match let's see who they're
gonna pick as they go through the button
checks and as you'll notice on the menu
you have these intricate menu options to
customize your play including release
check alternate control and other
options that you'll be familiar with
from other nether realm titles Sonya
Blade looks to be the selection from
sonic Fox and raid in front rewind
rewind are you ready he's ready sonic
Fox is ready let's get this final match
started to the commentators David David
I have a scorching-hot tape okay you
heard it here first okay and this may be
bold and I might get blown up for it but
I'm gonna do it cuz I'm about hot eggs
okay you are a student of the history of
fighting games correct here's my
statement I'll get your answer ok sonic
Fox is the most talented player to ever
pick up a pad over Tokyo and dagger Roth
I'm not saying length of tongue playing
results just raw give me give you a few
worms give me a few more years and all
that you know the answer to that but
right now he's on the very very short
list of all time absolutely already on
that list that's it if there is anyone
that could beat this guy in another own
game it is his cost grunt reward
they play a lot for six guys play
constantly yeah they were the grand
finals of the Justice to Pro Series
grand finals now ReWalk playing Raiden
is actually no surprise that's when we
play didn't pass and he wasn't as
well-known he really blew up into
justice too but in case he's had a
resurgent he's embodying people
displacer rating mm-hmm yeah and this
character seems a little bit different
it seems maybe a little bit more like a
zoning and puts these characters I would
definitely describe this as owning or
like footsie character for sure
this man is already pressing buttons
between strings I really just did that
this actually oh really oh very very
close now rewind is nutty enough to go
for his crushing blow oh wow that was
fast
now that lightning movie has a closed
meeting with our version of that okay he
also has excellent range with his
normals yeah even from this range you
can attack
Tiggy uses a staff and a lot of mourners
and his punches and kicks have really
good hits back one - oh wow
what's that may be a wrong throw tech is
that why there was a blow okay that
makes sense okay got it correctly that
time that Sony is a good pick for Sonic
box she unlike a lot of care she doesn't
use a weapons to her ranges some of the
shortest in this version of the game but
she makes up for with really really good
mix up she has like a very lonely mood
list and she has a lot of overhead and
low mix ups they're all not safe but she
makes you guess constantly like her back
one two there's the second hits an
overhead and then she has a load of
compliments oh she's very much a
high-risk high-reward mix up character
which in Sonic's so good at predicting
how you're gonna blob sure mixing you up
it's a great character now that
definitely makes sense to me unfortunate
for Sonic he's having a lot of trouble
actually getting going
because Raiden is so good in the
mid-range Raiden is also a character
with a custom character variations
really sets him apart he he has his
classic moves you'd expect to teleport
the the Superman but he has a lot of
light gear it's very wacky moves he
actually has a stance where he starts
hovering in the air we showed it to you
and he has like four different moves out
of it yeah he's got a move that's he
actually puts his staff into the ground
and it's planted and that he could do
his lightning moves to bounce off of it
a lot of kind of trap or setup moves
that he chooses to use those at the end
of the last round when he was going for
the chip out kill was there anything
that Sonic could have done is there like
a push blob or is there anything in that
sense there is the flawless block where
chip is dramatically reduced and he got
a reversal so that's kind of how you'd
want to push block in this game it's
very high skill survivability if you
block one hit of a string and the next
hit of this string do you have to
continue the input
you do not you could hold block and
you'll still get the reduced shipping so
yeah you're good enough to get it going
you know you can survive stuff you'd
normally be killed by what if you block
the first hit of a string regularly can
you then do the special timing block for
the second out of it it depends on how
big the gap is in this string I can't
remember off the top my head what the
frame do you know okay the Nerds can
look into that foundation later there
sir but yeah they're real nice scenarios
where there's enough of a gap and you
can fly us walk the second then punish
but not on a tight string right they're
pretty close chase down for sonic Fox
you can see those buttons out of rate
and are big right yeah very fast forward
movement so her onion rings are actually
really really really good in this game
they recover really it's kind of like
Morocco where they're surprisingly you
normally wouldn't think of her onion
rings as being super super strong but
they are okay and we saw briefly I don't
know that we've seen it actually connect
but Raiden has a huge anti-air gigantic
core drains on that
that shot so good now this really shows
the fatal blow but candy comes because
he is now made this comeback but sonic
is now inflated fatal blow territory
right and she had to overhead and a load
that could linked into it so everyone
could be on a ton of trouble if Sonic
gets it that Sonic got in he might go
for it
keeping it safe let's go into the
pressure oh yeah that was the low yeah
yes Sonic's doing a really good job just
kind of getting the mid range than
blocking go big jump back okay tries to
get out of the corner the short hop it's
so impressive that these guys I mean
that these guys are Evo champions they
are already using a mechanic like that
out of the rings okay but newsreel I
can't afford that right now he's too low
on life and reruns just one basically
throw or a low even if shifty was up on
this it's okay okay there you guys
and air support
my favorite detail here is the intestine
attached to the blade now since we've
been seeing a lot of projectiles tucked
me how the flawless block works against
projectiles well basically it's exactly
the same if you block it you know at the
last second you're not gonna take the
chip damage or cover a lot faster so you
can definitely use that if you're really
getting zoned out to block one perfectly
and obviously it'll be easier to print
to a flawless blocker projectile since
you see it's coming
going back to the zoning game again
we've seen a lot of this coming at a
rate in oh you know I just saw you ask
four questions on Twitter and someone
asked are the brutalities yeah baby okay
I don't know that's something I would
ask players here I don't know okay I
don't know the answer to that they were
definitely a cool feature and MKX I hope
they're bad okay
okay some pressure enough with sonic
boxes he moves forward sonic Fox is
definitely adjusted here after that
first game all that mace is in play
though let's save the interactable names
and remember you can amplify an
interactive will to get armors one of
the few ways you can armor in this game
so that's a pretty useful okay oh that
kill
what was that I believe that one is if
you block the first try to flawless
block the second a whole family Wow that
gets pretty involved John mortgage your
house on that but I think that's what it
is yeah yeah that good like a ton of
damage that's super sick condition so
you have an incentive to not try I guess
very cool if you know you're not exact
what your timing Oh
the uppercut uppercuts are like really
good in this game yeah it seems like a
lot of characters have great hit bucks
on it that was the beginning of Superman
right there which you can cancel
actually yes you can actually delay the
Superman if you kind of levitate for you
can cancel it now you can't cancel it
forever because it takes some of your
stamina but it's a pretty good fake out
I'm sorry I'm sorry Sonic could steal
this with fatal blow if he wants oh no
that was that an tires how that move
just shuts you down like you're no we
can't jump to so I thought that the
hitbox was at the bottom but it's the
actual lightning now read it it's not
tracking rate it has to know close
meaning or far but yeah that's that's
definitely a do not move sir Wow
and Sonic is really making hay with
those rings oh great tap mm-hmm these
guys are already checking each other
suppose and playing patience and
mid-range yeah I really like watching
Sonic just sort of move forward and XOR
ibly it's not super fast each time but
you can see I'm consistently doing it
what are these two friends gonna do when
they're not playing this game every day
is chilly occur like this flight is
going to be such a Nemo flight for them
yeah we're gonna be hype to play all day
long
ready for the tech and at the right
angle on it oh there and there you saw
the amplified spirit the armor that's a
good vanish all he needs is chip Sonic
could easily hold the critical mistake
sonocent attaching that fatal blow
Noah not any takes one more hit a chip
he's done
wait no okay this is the classic sonic
box rewind set yeah
rewind didn't forget about the teleport
he was ready with that and that's one of
those situations where I guess he just
won't have any other options right or
actually you know I'm not sure exactly
how much life he had but if he had
blocked that perfectly if he'd done
flawless block could he have survived
chip instead of we'd have to look I'm
guessing he still would have died I
don't remember exactly how much he had
so that isn't a void ship death it
doesn't afford it completely or chip
death but it does do significantly less
oh yeah it really does matter I just
don't remember that light I have to see
that again okay
while they're both and even live very
good use of radians teleport which I
absolutely love the animation this this
the way he turns around to do it is
super cool I was going to say everyone's
hanging around by that mates knowing an
amp live in any teleported away right oh
that's probably it
no choose why sonic chooses not to use
the fatal blow that certainly could have
done it huh
I guess maybe he wants to save it for
the next HemoCue life he's gonna win
this round anyways so he does what a
cool decision you have to make oh yeah
it's very very cool better and he did so
he was right and he was right so now if
he's in a bad spot or if he could just
steal game it'll still Hannibal do that
and since everyone used it but it was
blocked he'll happen again it only it
only catches out if it actually hits
very good zoning from these two do you
know if that's advantage that big moving
forward kind of red punch oh my god the
range on it is absurd the lightning bolt
is the hitbox so yeah you can even hit
and shout back so radiant is so good on
the ground and he could really mess you
up for trying to jump he seems really
strong yeah I think I think I think this
is a strong consideration and a many 50
games in my opinion he's great it's cool
I also really love personally how tall
and huge he is yeah he's cool looking
for sure like this is a in k1 lore it
actually
and he was extremely tall and I don't
think we've ever really shown how big he
is he is a big big guy you pick over the
low and he Sonic's got it all right ties
it up to two going down to the end I
think this is exactly what we expected
from these two players yeah I have other
ones they're definitely gonna hug
there's definitely gonna be a hug
there's just no doubt there's gonna be a
hug and I think sonic pox actually has a
cold so he'll transfer that with the hug
okay rewind they can be sick together
while tweeting about how sick and OD
degaton's Lister on my Rassman by sonic
fox but not only to the corner Oh was it
great Connery yeah that's that is her a
custom variation group that she has on
this slowdown she has a high counter and
a low count
wow that damage was wild at the end
right there so it's match point for
sonic Hawks see if we one chooses to
zone tell it what's on the corner very
smart oh that was an indicator on
styling attire that was good I didn't
seem like I canceled either that just
look like a link Sonic's in a lot of
trouble is Sonic going to lose his first
set it's not gonna start his Olympic
career
oh the tail all right here we go last
round
I'll see if Sonic can clips this out
with the K yeah there he goes the
confirm from rewind he's got corner that
would be a combo you can actually he
made one sorry standard just doesn't
know if it's early that is so good that
likes that angle that that thing takes
sonic just inching his way in we want
doing a great job with his own he may be
a little panic on the teleport though
confirmed properly and back to trying
for the Sony game the sonic fox is a big
threat
oh wow that was some rolling pin balls
there that was just enough light to get
it to great situation right now in terms
of that resource of a rewind that was a
very risky break yeah he was certain
though you know everyone wants to hit
that trigger cuz it will kill at this
point probably but oh he might get the
opportunity there still is the break I
have a little bit
time it was just a few frames away from
beat sonic bucks literally probably
three frames or so from losing this
exhibition well that was a great set
that's exactly what these two guys
though super close here's a hot take for
you we're gonna see this in many Grand
Finals to come well let's go back up to
Josh who has a word with sonic Fox well
that was one hell of a series but we
have a request from chat they want to
see one more match ladies and gentlemen
let's hear one more time for Tweety this
will be our final row exhibition Tweety
we'll be facing off against sonic Fox
any words before we start I'm gonna try
to mob but that makes looks good it's a
good mix going take a seat we'll get you
down to the button checks that was quite
a series against rewind but sonic Fox
you're gonna try to hold the title once
again up here are you folks having a
good time we saw a lot of great gameplay
we saw a lot of great surprises this is
going to be the final piece of our live
broadcast we think everybody for tuning
in we still got a little bit more left
to go as we showcase Mortal Kombat 11
tweeting it's good to get his lucky
controller connected and jump into the
button checks sonic Box could have
checked the mix-up and get rid of
himself
let's easy to choose the same character
and what
Tweety's is going to bring to the mix
here we go back into the menus
and of the character select screen once
again these players will have time to
check their inputs make sure their
Tweety is gonna double-check something
here
need some help from Aquaman here Thank
You mr. Aquaman so far we've seen Baraka
Sonia Blaine see some scorpion I don't
think we've seen any sub-zero yet seen
Raiden we see some scarlet we've seen
some Karras
I'd love to hear from you online social
media which characters you most excited
to see so far in Mortal Kombat 11
looks like we have the connection Tweety
is sitting down and he's in the menu
double check in the connection one more
time
so I'm gonna go into the main menu
[Music]
all right we're gonna give tweeting a
couple more moments here to get his
controller set up sonic box I'm gonna
ask you real quick how close was that
rewind matchup for you that was just if
you didn't notice each other fatal blow
me if I got hit by that I would have
died but I definitely I don't think
quitter blows are armored but I think
that quick so what I did what I did was
check it that's the case I took a fatal
blow at building and why have you here
what are your thoughts on the fatal
blows compared to the x-ray system that
we saw in previous Mortal Kombat games
that definitely a lot more useful now
like and maybe not want to use actually
the last game because the most most
literally useless I mean it was when
we're in like now that that system
exists it's like that's a big damage do
you think there's gonna be a lot of
strategy for players going in where they
want to use the fatal blow in the first
round or save it for the second round
and trying to find out when is the best
way to use it I think the best way to
use the fitted blows if it's gonna
secure you the game especially making
them full life come back well sonic
thanks for your thoughts we're gonna
give Tweety a couple more moments here
let me kick it over to the commentaries
we get this final matchup
underway now josh said that we haven't
seen sub-zero yet yeah I saw a little
bit of sub-zero in the back but talk to
me about how he is to see much different
yeah he almost is a weapons fighter in
this game he uses his eye he uses ice
swords and ice axes in a ton of his
normal attacks he has great range good
mix ups he has a low the can combo an
overhead that can combo the overhead is
unsafe but still very very good I heard
that he doesn't have a move that he
often has had in the past that has
figured quite prominently in his game
plan ice cones gone there's no ice
Claire is no ice clone somewhere on the
East Coast there is a certain player who
has just died it's frustrating he
actually does have a new move though
that functions kind of similarly that
you could check yeah the people here
will check out he has an ice or move
that's very very cool
right it seems to have a similar idea
maybe not the same function because you
can attack under it right and you can
jump over a little more easily and
that's one of his custom variation moves
so if you want to make a defensive
heavily play style one you can other
than that move I think he has a lot of
of ESP she has a lot of zoning rules in
this he has multiple different
projectiles he can use he's very very
different and I think he's very cool
I've always liked Sub Zero and I love
playing into this union like I've really
been interested in them but I really
like some of the changes in him one of a
projectile character at school so to me
D of course went back to the Baraka this
it makes a lot of sense he did really
really well
uh-huh now this is a that was because
when she won for a thrill she was going
for either a jab or throat okay so that
because that was a an uppercut to beat a
high attack yep you get the gun blow and
usually with an uppercut you're just
gonna knock down off the crushing blow
you're gonna fall combo so you know I
said earlier that combos aren't as
extensive that used to be using that
crushing blow you're actually gonna get
like 40 even up to 50% if you use the
crushing blow Wow okay but once per D so
you got to really make it count tried to
get the second one I think maybe if he
hadn't enhanced that he might have been
able to remember in time but took the
rest going for the rest and and so far
we haven't seen a lot of zoning they're
just going hand there's going in
yeah even Tweety hasn't really been
zoning didn't had that many chances the
stage actually have screwed of
interactive bills
oh wait a forward roll how about that
okay so as an escape not just the
defensive sort of moving backwards tool
but to get out of this one I in the
corner right yeah I think the wake up
roll is very very strong and as you
saying before that's invincible two hits
but can be grabbed it can be grabbed yes
and that includes command grabs like
Baracus command row actually beats it
and that is the crushing claw required
okay
yeah these guys are like on each other
like glue like they're the opposite
zoning right okay yeah there's the wake
up getting a little juggle out of it
fatal bullets ready
sonic quacks mention you thought that
okay that's it Wow as an anti-air juggle
from across the screen all that damage
that is crazy so much the soft mention
that crushing or sorry fatal blow
doesn't have armor that definitely is
that correct it's that the armor doesn't
start up immediately okay do you have to
wait a little bit but he is right that
they're very very fast the the end two
attacks that lead to a fatal blow are
very very strong you can see it looks
like Tweety is trying to find some ways
to back up get back start the zoning
again it's been hard for him
oh good pre-emptive jump attack that's
injustice fundamentals right there and I
love the brought guys the classic you
take you drop kid yeah let's exact that
Randy Orton Bob Holly drop kick but jump
effects new work a little bit
differently for example neutral jump
punches don't launch in the way that
they've done in the last couple of yes
stay an hour the sand scorpion actually
has a variation move you can equip that
gives him the old school like volleyball
balance thing if he wants oh it didn't
kill I knew it
very good blocks in Sonic
really could use the flawless block I
guess he's got in the corner sweetie can
actually wall run off that dirty
Fentress nope he's not gonna have to I
like it rolls away
this is relentless right now sonic Fox
is making everything happening
okay yeah didn't expect second hit oh
it's just the Cape so so noble vigor
combo out of this now we see the zoning
now Tweety's in doing exactly what he
wanted to do and yeah Sonic's gonna be
in a lot of trouble so sure her range
isn't the best she's gonna have to
either do her projectile back or kind of
inch or way in long if you go got a
knockdown out of there very smart a
tweeted again and justice fundamentals
they're using that wall run to get a
dodge to the only tried to go I said in
an hour ago no one has ever punished
Chop Shop ever in 30 years well you can
keep it up that's tricky
it is you see everyone says Oh chop chop
stab at it just punish it it's bad and
if no one does oh that baraka back for
to move is so quick it's punishable but
that scoop is very very fast that's kind
of like a zoom cannot wait charge but
significantly better man that jump kick
has really been causing sonic locks
problems you see them trying to
anti-area a couple of times they both
failed oh wow he goes to the Restatement
goes for another mix-up both are in
fatal blow here we scramble tried it but
again because it was blocked he still
has it again yes he will have it under
cool you'll see when it comes to
[Music]
Sonic's gonna be up to us very close
games though so he's holding his own oh
yeah
[Music]
on expedia needs to call air scourges
Starfire
even though that projectiles amid the
way the sonic fox moves through it is
still practiced seemingly you know it's
like he's already had experience that
what's scaring me right now is sonic
doesn't have his paws and he's still
od'd like this isn't even his full form
he literally doesn't have his hands and
he's still beating and they're both
going all in again yeah I don't know if
anybody really knows what is advantage
or not right now sorry that for for that
Sonia the move is definitely one of her
better bids it's so fast and it's
awesome to see Sonic that said punished
yeah already has figured out some of you
know some of her great close-range moves
even with just this limit amount of time
yeah
Wow look at this this is a clinic right
now I find it crosses it off peepee oh
my god this is reminding me of last time
a Mortal Kombat game came out and sonic
knew the game instantly like the way is
using back one is it's just exactly what
you want to do with her like
he basically figured out some gangsta
fundamentals and in like four minutes
right he's he just thinks so fast we'll
see though treaty has made these games
competitive so
yeah he's not gonna or hasn't been
getting smoked although you might say
this game smoked excellent roll Sonic's
gonna reverse its Tweety's in a ton of
trouble here yeah that roll was ok but
ok here we go now Sonic might be
infinite more territory himself right
now or it's gonna be very close very
very close
not quite but still if he finds the
right hit it's over and sonic box ends
up taking it in a sweep today 2-0 I
think sonic just let sweetie know look
bud this is it ok I gotta tell you I
really enjoyed seeing the different
styles that we saw among the characters
we saw that it was a slope on a patient
offense mix-ups up close from Sonia we
saw very strong zoning at a couple of
the carrot garlic Baraka mm-hmm that's
right we saw some cool command grab
mix-ups as well sometime freezing stuff
out of Garris I'm really liking what the
variety is shaping up to be there's only
a few characters in there but they're
not quite different with a custom
character thing you can actually again
like Garris you could make him not a
grappler and make him a capo zoning
character or scorpion actually has some
debuffs and buffs and scorpion has a
state's a really cool
he sheets the sword samurai and then he
has multiple moves out of it so and 50
50s and stuff there's all kind of stuff
that we haven't even seen yet cuz they
were just using the default variation
one here yeah everyone in the show floor
you're gonna I mean make sure you check
out the streams that are content
creators are doing and look at the
tweets and all that because there's all
kind of content the game with the custom
variation thing that we didn't even
showcase that's true and these
variations that they were showing what
kind of the more digestible variations
right the weird stuff is was not
necessarily what we saw on screen even
though again that was a really good
variety there the weirder stuff is
remaining great just just because they
didn't have a lot of time we kind of had
them to use that default one and leaves
next like a slug the bread-and-butter
kind of moves like for example you can
actually have a loadout where sub-zero
doesn't have sly he can have a bunch of
free he actually has this really cool
movie shoots a bunch of ice starts and
it's like I didn't see that he has a big
mid projectile where he waves his arms
and shoots a giant full
Green projectile so you can use a sewing
substitute so yeah if you are an old
washed-up old gun and you have slow
reactions and no footsies you can make a
zoning sub-zero okay
I'm talking about me talking about I see
I see yeah
and in that one you don't have the ice
not clone ice ball right what it's
called well you can make a pure
offensive sub-zero if you want it's
pretty much up to you yeah I mean and I
had a chance to experiment with things a
little bit and and I got to say I really
like how different each of the
characters can feel like they can they
can feel very very very different you
know I spend most of my time with garrus
and even that character I better believe
I did not give up the command grab all
right I have this plan to come and grab
but even even with that the other
options he has taken 30 seconds off the
clock that's the one of the Troy 30
seconds to the clock we're winding
himself back for seconds including to
how much life he had forces yes we saw a
hint of that in his gameplay reveal
trailer so I can't wait to see the
impressions coming out of this show the
people that use the rewind move because
it's pretty ingenious very very cheap
it's supper to you imagine being a
grappler where you can with your command
grab and as you're getting punished go
not go and rewind time yeah are you
saying that you can use it during hit
stun it's it's pretty cheap very very
cheap I love it all right well I've had
a really good time watching the players
up here I mean already figuring so many
things out so quickly yeah this is just
our preview what's awesome all those
guys are there as soon as honey be lost
that first set he was in the back
playing more you know it definitely
absolutely right
alright hey thanks a lot appreciate it
that was very cool let's go back up to
Josh she's gonna have a few more words
to say thank you gentlemen
all right well that's gonna do it for
today's show before you wrap we do want
to show everybody at home what it's like
to be here at the show floor a big thank
you to all of our players our
commentators and our crew a thank you to
everyone who tuned in you are the heart
and soul of this community and we love
you dearly and of course taking another
realm for giving us a taste of Mortal
Kombat 11 early here at MK day 2019 for
those of you watching at home don't
forget to pre-order your copy today more
information can be found at mortal
matcom I'm Joshua gray good night and
good game
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now it's time to check out what's going
on here on the stone floor today at the
MK 11 reveals nether
all right so first up for the photo
booths and there are actually two going
on
they're all different the enemy into a
gym and it's really cool you get to use
up your bodies as your prop
[Music]
this is a collective exhibit bunch of
our really great art what that entails
is there are some bunch of items in
there you can go all out and destroy
them with different items and weapons
but anyways about to check it out and
let out some steam you know let's let
off get my range on get my fatality on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]